[Music]
in stay in history news halos black and
red black and red whoa you guys broke it
out forget it forget it do we cut like
just shot submitted by I love Steve
wrote you wrong I didn't I swear he did
you changed just kidding
we're playing Hitler whatever it is oh
yeah that's true people believe people
believe will believe that I would
believe that you I haven't read it yet
okay I'm so sorry the Watergate Hotel is
fully embracing its scandalous history
with a new guest Nixon package right so
this is pretty weird so the watery
hotels like how could we get people to
spend money at our hotel we need some
kind of [ __ ] gimmick some kind of
thing to do are they losing money well I
think it's really just about like what
could we do to increase business right
yeah where is it Watergate Hotel I think
it's yeah it's in DC I'm surprised they
haven't done anything around this sooner
actually true
yeah true well especially like the I was
thinking they should do like a haunted
house there but you know nobody wanted
to [ __ ] do my idea wait so first
explain the history part okay so what's
water Watergate is a scandal that
happened during the Nixon administration
where five people who were connected to
the Republican Party at the time
burglarized the Watergate Hotel which
was where the DNC had a bunch of
information that they were after to try
to whatever the [ __ ] they they were just
trying to get they're trying to dig up
dirt right they're finding data Nixon's
Republican and so these cats were all
arrested eventually and charged and
there was a criminal conspiracy that
happened in Nixon's administration was
trying to cover it up and that's
ultimately why he ended up having to
resign before his listen there's
something to do with illegal wiretapping
and car
he was recording myself and then he
self-incriminating a lot okay okay he
ended up having testimony against
himself that you know worked against him
he resigned because it was just looking
nuts and everyone was like where you're
going down from because he tried to
cover it up he really wasn't involved in
the original scandal but it's because he
tried to cover it all up that at all in
protecting his people exactly he was
trying to keep the scandal from making
his people look better and it's all cuz
Forrest Gump saw those flashlights over
there and I know exactly okay so so what
the watergate hotel is there like [ __ ]
it we're gonna embrace this [ __ ] right
mm-hmm so they have a new guest package
where if you want to stay at the hotel
scandal room someone's gonna rummaging
through your [ __ ] every night that's
better
oh no they recreated the room right so
in the scandal room it's like it looks
like the site of exactly how it was at
the time but then they have like a bunch
of paraphernalia about about the
Watergate like including the DNC had an
office in the hotel a lot of during
campaigns and stuff they post up in
different places and yeah like in
Ocean's eleven when they're about to rob
the own hotel they set up shop within
the it's exactly so guess who booked I
was thinking the same thing
guess who booked the quote arrested at
Watergate package will also be treated
to drinks with John Barrett and Paul
Lieber and they were the DC police
officer officers who responded to the
burglar yes you drink with the with
these guys yeah some guys who respond to
the burn people alive so it's kind of
its kind of like a meet and greet don't
yeah story if you're into it well
because you guys aren't into it but if
someone that was like ah okay they're
like oh I get to like first like I get
to hear these stories firsthand that's
isn't there Alcatraz jail tour with one
of the guys that used to go there and
then he's like yeah that was my sale
I've been on the tour I didn't have that
guy that will do but it's like special
pay though like I have the plastic thing
that you stick the headphones in I tell
you the stories all around
I like tours it's like the Manson
murders are like what if you got to like
hang out with some of the police
officers who showed up on the scene like
from history and you're like ah I'll
talk to you about that and like feel
their face and be like you're real yeah
you are the pan yeah exactly like sir
are you blind it's like no I just
partner you feel that way about old
people when I sit down and talk to him I
love it oh you're like a flesh movie
yeah even you when I talk to you
remember that well we're having dinner
you're in there's a lot older than you I
do agree I don't know yes I'm telling me
his entire family history and I'm like
it would your grandma work in and what
happened is so interesting especially
because I have pictures for it to yeah
well I investigate my family like a
detective really yeah because I want to
know why they [ __ ] up mmm I do is
there anyone that you're like I respect
this person from know there fuk there a
line of fuck-ups except my great grandpa
he was a [ __ ] boss he was a Toshiba
executive yeah it's pretty nuts like my
my whole entire grandma side of the
family they would wake up before him the
whole house is like basically he's a
team and he gets everything ready and
when he's about to go outside they line
up like a [ __ ] like service yeah in
order of hierarchy they bow and him he
gets in with this personal driver and
when he gets to the company they [ __ ]
line up like that too and all the
executives walk in every single [ __ ]
day sound the music and [ __ ] like the
hierarchy it's like who's the one that's
like okay you're gonna stand here and
you're gonna stand over there
oh like you know it's usually the wife
first confucianism i'll confusion it's
pretty like built-in where you just kind
of just know like it's like like let's
say if I know
my uncle's house and on my uncle's house
a head of this household and then his
wife is the second person in command if
I need a gift
food if I want snacks at all ask her if
she's not around my little cousin who is
now like that I guess the second
matriarch will step up and buy snacks
like you know it's just it's just it
just falls into place it's like so much
order so the idea behind this whole
thing is you get to stay in the room
that the Watergate scandal first
happened in and you get to relive the
experience what's the experience
oh they heard a chick they heard the
chick who did all the set design for
scandal and they had her like designed
the room and make it look all sick no
her name's like Lynne no this show
scandal you have a show scandal they
should do that at the Japanese American
Museum hey you want to know what it's
like to be taken to an internment camp
and then they take away all your stuff
and then you just rob the [ __ ] pay
the people that come to the music that's
the experience you paid for it yeah
that's fun people are paying $2,500 yeah
to stay in the room fine I don't know if
it was Disneyland or Knott's Berry Farm
but there's the stagecoach [ __ ] guys
that come on the train and then they
[ __ ] rob you and then they kidnapped
people and I'm like oh I always wanted
to get picked
that's very farmed so fun thank you was
it nice burger thank you yeah I can't
see anything I'm sad because I never got
picked when we were just at comic-con I
weird me me and TIFF and Nikki we're all
just [ __ ] around afterward cuz we had
do we had to do a podcast after and
we're walking the floor and all of a
sudden I look over and I'm like holy
[ __ ] that's the lady from [ __ ] Star
Trek oh yeah and she was just chilling
there she's like we yeah like the the
old one from the original series in
shape movies so I was and she's just
chilling there and no one gave a [ __ ] no
we gave it a [ __ ] dude she was thinking
fuzzy but like one person did she have
her Star Trek you know uniform on no I
mean how people wanna know if they don't
the old lady old lady old lady who I saw
two two ladies with really big titties
it was dead
like this and I was so shocked because I
see a teacher it was this big and they
were like [ __ ] purple and veiny like
[ __ ] skin didn't look right it look
like it's filled with pus it was it
looked like fake skin like the wax
museum sketch and she had that look on
her face like you guys like big titties
and of course she was kind of like like
looking at everyone's eyes and then
being like yeah you're looking at what
else are we gonna look at freak yeah but
how would you not look at those I'm
looking at the whole time look at you I
want to feel them no they want to feel
them too how do you know that I feel
them I'm telling you the skin looked
hairy though it was more like fear
factor more than desire yeah yeah the
big Katie ones no big titty one have to
you know that one woman who grabs your
titties and the smashes watermelons oh
wow I'm Gina she [ __ ] vaporizes
watermelons are there ten and just one
like that's how huge it is you're a fat
[ __ ] there are some chicks that think
like dudes out there each tip can be a
[ __ ] galaxy dude the end and it's
proven that time moves slower around
bigger objects so time is moving slower
around those titties I did feel weight
slower like those going through it we
slow because we all stopped and loved to
a lot of people around the whole thing
they were just like what and she was
like loving every single stare and the
bigger the object the more gravitational
pull it has Oh
so you couldn't even help it we were
feeling maybe a little bit of that damn
me it has mass on microscopic oh maybe
you like you age slower if you just hang
out around her titties because if time
stops then you're aging you're gonna be
like this little baby she's 200 actually
but she just looked 60 her own
gravitational I think titties make
people feel young all kind of titties
nice titties like perky titties that
would agree but salutation yeah like if
you're around a parrot oh yeah that's
the way they make you feel just in your
presence and if you just like breast
milk forever keeps you young
I thought you're talking about getting
breast milk all over your face huh no
have y'all had before no I need to get
some I've never taste
I've never tasted out of curiosity what
do you squeeze it like this channel of
warm cantaloupe
hi did you shoot it in your mouth no
ma'am you're brave that sounds good but
why I was so focused on the kid like a
dumbass you're the first person I think
would be like hey can I try that also
focus on the kids focus on seeing if the
kid will latch on to his nipple that he
was like he tried it out of my [ __ ]
mouth that's a good experiment yes he
was to like Lotus jelly have you tried
the cantaloupe flavored soy milk no Dan
has that shit's bomb is it is that what
city milk tastes like no I'm just
wondering if that's what her she tasted
but it wasn't sweet like it was like
lightly sweet but it wasn't like sugary
sweet would you recommend it - yeah
would you be like kind of got a little
grossed out cuz I don't like warm milk
stuff I like warm said I'd like put in
my latte thank you at certain
restaurants or breast milk yeah I
remember we did it we did an article
here where you can order breast milk
I do remember breast milk oh yeah so fun
other breast milk let me tell you man
when she was finally pregnant and she
starts lactating Orlac is that the word
doctor nice I'm I'm on that [ __ ]
what if you're lactose intolerant I'll
risk it yeah I'll report back to you
guys we make guys can be making some
cottage cheese you say what you make a
nice creamy making a cottage cheese huh
ice cream breast milk breast milk ice
cream let me know we'll come over yeah
come to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]